hello there guys and welcome to another
video regarding spider-man no way home
in this video i'm going to show you a
couple clips of tom holland reacting to
the spider-man trailer now this clip was
actually released some time ago but
there's not a lot of people speaking
about it as you can clearly see tom
holland is holding something back and he
seems disappointed for some reason and
i'll get into that right now
where's the this is all my fault i can't
save it so tom holland here he nearly
blurts something out he says where's the
and then just stop now this could mean
anything really but the timing of this
this is when we see the villains arrange
themselves and we see um tom holland
spider-man do a hero land in but however
we do know this is the scene where other
spider-man have most likely been edited
out now i have done a video regarding
this if you haven't seen that then
please go check that out anyway so when
tom holland says where's the do you
think he's referring to love of
spiderman do you think he was gonna say
where's delta spiderman you know that
could be a long reach but you can
reasonably see for the rest of the
trailer um he looks visibly disappointed
now this could just be the type of
person he is when reacting to stuff but
in saying that there's other scenes in
the trailer we get very hyped up and
stuff so i'm not too sure they're
starting to come through
now the end of the trailer seems like
it's possible that tom holland may have
nearly blurted or spoiled something out
again he says that's and then just cuts
off now he looks very disappointed when
the trailer ends potentially he was
waiting for tease of another spider-man
like we all were or again this could
just be a big coincidence but this is a
long reach i will admit that but it's
not too long until we all find out it's
about a week and a half from release so
please tell me what you guys think of
this in the comment section below do you
think tom holland nearly spoiled
something here or is this just a long
reach you know over that out of the way
please like and subscribe if you haven't
and turn on notifications to show your
support thanks for watching guys